getting things is not gonna make you
happy
it doesn't matter what you get all those
things might excite you for the moment
you know even a relationship as
magnificent it may be might be exciting
for a while but if you don't keep
growing that relationship isn't gonna
stay exciting progress equals happiness
and if we can make progress on a regular
basis we feel alive and that's why at
the beginning of the year we get this
thing like okay I can have this fresh
start I could really do what my soul
desires I could expand I could grow I
could improve I could change or maybe
better than change I could progress if
the economy is gonna change no matter
what you want it to do the weather is
gonna change relationships are gonna
change everything in life is always
changing we have to work on change
change is automatic but progress is not
so if you want to make real progress
then you really got to look at your life
in a different way
you gotta say I gotta take control of
this process and not just hope that's
gonna work out like people do who make a
resolution treat people at the end of
the relationship like it's the beginning
and it won't be an end and that's not
just your intimate relationships what if
you fell in love with your customers
with your clients more than your product
more than your company if your entire
life was about meeting their needs if
you would do what for your customers
crime she would do what if you love your
customers and clients you'd do anything
guess what they're gonna love you you
want clients for life not just customers
fall in love with them
but most people love their customers and
clients as long as they buy from them do
what they want respond to them and then
they don't they go that's the end you
want clients for a life not just
customers fall in love with them it's a
different focus isn't it it's a
different meaning and that creates a
different life because you make
decisions differently from that place
you just watched two amazing clips from
Tony Robbins take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life
believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]